The problem with scaling
gradient descent is simple.
You need to compute this gradient.
Here is another rule of thumb.
If computing your loss takes
n floating point operations,
computing its gradient takes
about three times that compute.
As we saw earlier,
this last function is huge.
It depends on every single
element in your training set.
That can be a lot of compute
if your data set is big.
And we want to be able to train
lots of data because in practice
on real problems you will always get
more gains the more data you use.
And because gradient
descent is intuitive,
you have to do that for many steps.
That means going through your
data tens or hundreds of times.
That's not good, so instead,
we're going to cheat.
Instead of computing the loss, we're
going to compute an estimate of it,
a very bad estimate,
a terrible estimate in fact.
That estimate is going to be so bad,
you might wonder why it works at all.
And you would be right,
because we're going to also have to
spend some time making it less terrible.
The estimate we're going to use is
simply computing the average loss for
a very small random fraction
of the training data.
Think between 1 and
1000 training samples each time.
I say random because
it's very important.
If the way you pick your
samples isn't random enough,
It no longer works at all.
So, we're going to take a very small
sliver of the training data, compute
the loss for that sample, compute the
derivative for that sample and pretend
that that derivative is the right
direction to use to do gradient descent.
It is not at all the right direction,
and
in fact at times it might increase
the real loss, not reduce it.
But we're going to compensate
by doing this many, many times,
taking very, very small steps each time.
So each step is a lot
cheaper to compute.
But we pay a price.
We have to take many more smaller steps,
instead of one large step.
On balance, though, we win by a lot.
In fact,
as you'll see in the assignments,
doing this is vastly more efficient
than doing gradient descent.
This technique is called
stochastic gradient descent and
is at the core of deep learning.
That's because stochastic gradient
descent scales well with both data and
model size, and
we want both big data and big models.
Stochastic gradient descent, SGD for
short, is nice and scalable.
But because it is fundamentally a pretty
bad optimizer, that happens to be
the only one that's fast enough, it
comes with a lot of issues in practice.